اعمال العنف والشغب الاسوا من سنوات في
فرنسا بدات تتراجع هذه الاعمال اللي فجر
شرارتها مقتل الشاب الفرنسي نائل ذو
الاصول الجزائريه المغربيه على يد الشرطي
احتجاجات وحرائق وفوضى وتكسير وتخريب ونهب
وغيرها ملت باريس ومناطق اخرى في فرنسا
والاف الاعتقالات سيطرت على اخبار فرنسا
لايام على الرغم من القبض على الشرطي اللي
اطلق النار على نائل وتوجيه تهمه القتل له
ومن بعد اخبار في البدايه انه نائل كان
مخالف للقانون لاحقا طلع صاحبه اللي كان
معه ونشر فيديو وتفاصيل للحادث وقال انه
ما كان حتى عاملين شيء غلط
وحقيقه اللي صار حول الموضوع من مجرد قضيه
فرديه لناقل لحراك عام وانقسام ففي عندنا
مهاجرين ومواطنين الامه من الجيل الثاني
او اكثر من المهاجرين هذول شايفين انهم
بيتعرضوا للعنصريه والتمييز وحقوقهم
مهضومه ونائل صار رمز لهم
امامهم يميني اكثر ومعادل المهاجرين
والشرطه او صارت او الشرطي نفس هذا صار
رمز لهم شفنا كمان حملات تبرع لكل من
عائله ناقل وعائله الشرطي هذه بالتحديد
عاد عملت جدل وانقسام اكبر واكبر خاصه
بسبب التفاوت الكبير في المبالغ المجموعه
عندنا عائله الشرطي للان ان جمعت لها
تبرعات باكثر من مليون و600 الف يورو اما
والده نائل فمن جمع لا اكثر من نصف مليون
يورو كتير ناس شايفه هذا مقياس ودليل على
اعداد الناس في المعسكرين وناس تانيه
شايفه انه لا انهم هم بس المهاجرين واللي
في معسكرهم مو من الناس اللي معاها فلوس
مثلا او قادره تتبرع بمبالغ كبيره لكن صور
ومقاطع كثيره متعلقه بنهاله وقصه طويل في
فرنسا صايره متداوله بشكل واسع وكثير منها
جلسه بتتضح حقيقته فالمعارضين لناقلوا
منتقدي نشروا صوره للشاب شايل سلاح وقالوا
انه هذه او انه الصور هذه نائل فرنسا
علشان ولكن الصوره في الحقيقه مو لنا الا
الصوره للشاب الفلسطيني اشرف السعدي اللي
قتل في جنين الشهر الماضي لكن يبدو في ناس
لسبب ما شبهتهم ببعد في صور ثانيه متداوله
بشكل واسع من اعمال الشغب كانت لبرج ايفل
بيحترق الصور هذه عملت صدمه واسعه عند
الناس وصاروا بيتساءلوا فعلا الحرائق
والتخريب وصلوا للمعلم الشهير لكن بالبحث
بين انه الصور مو حقيقيه واحده من هذه
الصور ماخوذه لاتخنه العاب ناريه في البرج
في اليوم الوطني عام 2005 بس الزاويه
مبينه كانه في حريق اما الصوره الثانيه
فمول البرج اصلا وانما لمجسم خشبي للبرج
احرق الشهر الماضي خلال احتفالات النادي
الفرنسي لكره القدم هو احتفال ثانوي
بيعملوا النادي وبيحرقوا خلاله مجسمات
خشبيه
[موسيقى]